speaking of other things that i'm
obviously right about
you you know i hate to say i told you so
but a lot of these things that we've
been talking about on this show in
particular have just been
jumping to the forefront of the media
and the news i've said for a long time
abortion is not about
freedom abortion is not about the right
to choose and you choose this and i
choose this and you know we all just
kumbaya man i've said abortion is
a religious sacrament that all politics
ultimately is religious if you think
that your politics is not rooted in
religion you're probably you're probably
really superstitious actually you're
you're probably
involved in a caricature of religion
because necessarily when we're making
moral decisions and ethical decisions
they come down to religion i said
abortion is especially especially
vulnerable to that
there's a video that's going around the
internet of of a young woman
who is teaching other women how to as
they prepare for their abortion and
after their abortion
build an actual altar at which to
worship
building an altar for your abortion can
be a really cathartic procedure can be a
really cathartic process because
it just creates
a space for your your sacred container
where you can return to
whenever you want to meditate whenever
you want to think deeply or contemplate
any aspect of your abortion it's a
really beautiful way to just give
reference to the experience
and hold the experience
in a really sacred way
i also really like to add the abortion
pills themselves to the altar
to really bless the pills that we're
going to be taking into our bodies
during this process and place the
container
of which you plan to put the the
products of conception or the fetal
remains within to catch that after
you've passed it and save it for later
when we when we find a way to
to bury or otherwise
to where we find a way to properly
dispose of the fetal remains in a way
that gives reverence and respect and
support to this
to the sacred abortion experience
that's a whole lot of thought and prayer
and liturgy and worship for a
meaningless clump of cells don't you
think right now head on over to tuvu.com
knowles it is time to take a stand and
stop feeding the big tech beast that
wants to cancel us and censor us and
isolate us from one another on social
media you have heard me talk a lot about
tuvu that is the new subscription-based
alternative on social media that weeds
out the bots and the trolls and the
invasive ads and most importantly the
algorithms that make big tech such a
toxic place tuvu is the photo sharing
community app built on family values
data privacy and freedom of opinion it's
time to move our communities our
families and our churches to a better
place online where big tech is not
pushing their agenda their vice their
addictive content and the damaging
material that they have out there to all
of our mental health tuvu is ad-free so
they answer to you the subscriber he who
pays the piper calls the tune on tuvu
your data will never be sold to
advertisers or data miners instead touvu
sells social media freedom to those who
use it for just 299 a month or 22.99 per
year that right there weeds out fakes
all along the way are you hesitant to
try a new platform well for the next
seven days only tuvu is giving our
listeners a free annual membership when
you go to
tuvu.com you'll get a free annual
membership get all the details in your
free annual subscription for a limited
time only at tuvu.com
head on over there right now do not miss
this opportunity t-u-v-u.com
knowles or look for the tuvu app on
google play or the app store
this video of this young woman
who is dressed just like the archetypal
millennial woman she's wearing yoga
pants she's in her
studio apartment in probably new york or
something
and she builds an altar she says on the
altar
for our abortion we're gonna put the
abortion drug and then
how spooky is this she says we're gonna
get a jar
that we're gonna put the product of
conception into and then she clarifies
what she means by that euphemism she
says
you know the fetal remains so she's
saying you know put the dead baby into
this little jar on the altar with some
incense with the abortion drugs and
you're going to worship at this sacred
altar
people are looking at this and they're
saying oh my gosh this is so this is the
craziest thing ever although can you
believe this yes i can believe this
because it's not the craziest thing ever
this is the norm in human history
it is a human sacrifice an actual
visible
undeniable human sacrifice
and that is the norm
not killing babies is the exception in
human history
in christian civilization we say no
human sacrifice no killing our babies no
we try to tamp down eugenics which
is also plays a huge role in abortion
and also has been practiced all around
the world since the dawn of time and the
christian civilization says no we're not
going to have any of that as
christianity declines in public
you're not going to have nothing you're
not going to have a vacuum you're not
going to have
neutrality you're going to have all the
same insane paganism that typifies the
rest of the world throughout all of
history that's going to come flooding
back in as it is with a vengeance
this is the normal state of things
if you don't like that normal state of
things with the human sacrifice and the
bacchanals and the orgies and the
the demon worship and all that kind of
stuff if you don't like that
then it is incumbent upon us
to
re-christianize our political order you
you hear the libs crying about christian
nationalism
as the the rise of christian nationalism
as as though this is the worst thing in
the world
christian nationalism is just the
opposite of atheist globalism
atheist globalism weird kooky pagan
wipe away our national borders wipe away
our traditions that's the abortion altar
okay that's the monkey pox orgies taking
place with government sanction that's
that's what that looks like if you don't
want that society your alternative right
now
is christian nationalism and we have not
only the right but the duty
to reimpose a normal
broadly christian society
in in our culture okay we have the right
to do that now what some people say will
say is well you know look abortions are
going to happen
abortions are going to happen and so
either they can be safe or dangerous
first of all no abortion is safe because
it always kills a baby
and but second of all even the premise
is kind of flawed
sure yes there will be
some abortions that take place even if
you outlaw abortion and even if you
stigmatize it in society but many fewer
will take place
when we had laws against abortion many
many many fewer abortions took place
if if that argument from the libs is
true look abortions are going to happen
anyway they might as well be legal well
look people are going to use drugs
anyway it might as well be legal well
it's the kind of liberal slash
libertarian argument if that were true
then that would be an argument for
getting rid of all the laws well look
murders are going to take place we might
as well we should just make sure that
murders don't go underground okay you
don't want it to be on we just need it
to be legal and regulated
look uh tax evasion is gonna occur but
we just need it we should have it be
illegal we should get rid of all of the
laws and then just have total anarchy
that's that's the conclusion of that but
no of course that's not the case when
you have laws against stuff you get less
of that stuff abortion obviously should
be illegal it should be stigmatized in
society and that which that sorceress
who was
showing you how to build an altar to the
human sacrifice of your of your dead
baby that woman should be totally
ostracized from society and should be so
ashamed that she doesn't show her face
in public that's what should happen
and we should have do that from the
cultural front
but also from the political front
because politics is downstream of
culture but culture is also downstream
of politics they they kind of work in
tandem it's actually very difficult to
differentiate between the two
i'm glad you like that clip now
look we made it to one million
subscribers that's really great i'm
getting my gold play button from youtube
it's fabulous they haven't nuked me yet
wonderful now next goal
1 trillion i want to get to 1 trillion
subscribers i can't do that without your
help you need to ring ding dong like
subscribe whatever you got to do get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]